Oh ladies brunch
oh hell yeah ladies ease it quits this
thing so it looks like it's a just a
regular cheeseburger except there's egg
bacon and of course at Krispy Kreme as
the bun let's do this mm-hmm well it
tastes pretty much exactly how you think
it would taste it's delicious
is it an innovation on a standard burger
no it looks like a peanutbutter sandwich
but there's white on it is that
marshmallow fluff just better not be
mayonnaise and peanut butter
whoa that's not moral applause was it
managed well this is man it's actually
good better than that time it would be
when you first told me scrapple I
thought it was gonna be a drink but it's
like trimmings and stuff that's it's
fried it smells like meat
it doesn't have a bad flavor but it has
a really weird texture just if there's a
winning formula for a human food fad
meat put that on fire and you got
delicious so here we have only Flo this
looks like a cartoon food it's the meat
equivalent of a fruitcake right I mean I
don't know why it's just all there
should be other things embedded in it
like even more meat oh my god nope
indefinitely no yeah it's like really
salty but I don't hate it I don't know
when you would be like well giving me
olive loaf as opposed to give me Pam or
give me spam or give me Turkey or
anything else I love love it's better
than Bologna
are these kool-aid pickles what I hate
pickles but I love kool-aid just purely
from an aesthetic standpoint this is
beautiful it's good I've never eaten
like a full pickle before like I take
one bite and spit it out but I want to
eat this full pickle mmm good my tongue
better than a normal pickle yeah
[Music]